pierre laurent secrétaire général du
parti communiste français et nouveau
sénateur depuis le mois d'octobre est
notre invité ce soir bonsoir
mechri d'être avec nous on va parler
bien entendu ensemble du rapport gallois
remis hier et puis des mesures retenues
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement en
séminaire pour relancer la compétitivité
française
ensuite katell prigent de la fp nous
rejoindra sur ce plateau pour vous
interroger sur vos rapports avec le
gouvernement et avec le parti socialiste
alors qu'on se demande de plus en plus
si vous êtes dans la majorité ou dans
l'opposition
et puis en fin d'émission mickaël szames
s de public sénat vous demandera
notamment où est la place l'avenir de
jean luc mélenchon mais pour commencer
donc pierre laurent sur l' architecture
générale du rapport gallois est ce que
tout est acheté comme l'a dit que ce
matin jean luc mélenchon oui je crois
que nous ne partageons ni le diagnostic
ni les solutions parce que ce diagnostic
ça consiste à nous dire c'est un thème
récurrent depuis des années porté par le
medef que le problème de de l'industrie
française est un problème de
compétitivité et que ce problème de
compétitivité c'est le coût du travail
nous récusons les termes de ce
diagnostic le problème de l'industrie
française ces deux choses c'est
l'absence de politique industrielle ou
depuis des années on a laissé la
stratégie des groupes dominé la
politique industrielle est en vérité la
mettre en pièces donc on n'a pas de
vision et pas d'ambition nationale pour
l'industrie française
et deuxièmement on a donné la priorité à
des stratégies de la comptabilité
financière qui prélève de la richesse
sur les entreprises et c'est ça le
problème est pas le travail qui au
contraire la richesse potentielle pour
pouvoir reconquérir mais l'industrie
alors le rapport gallois et les mesures
retenues par le gouvernement ne porte
pas que sur le coût du travail en partie
on va on va détailler différentes
mesures
ok ce que vous avez dit vous jeter à
l'eau aubin tout le rapport comme jean
luc mélenchon que le rapport va tourner
aujourd'hui pour le coeur du rapport
c'est la mesure qui est proposé c'est le
choc de compétitivité économique
lise le pacte de compétitivité de
collants d'accord on peut jouer sur les
mots mais au fond il s'agit de
transférer des plusieurs dizaines de
milliards sur les salariés au détriment
soi disant pour permettre le
développement de l'investissement
mais si les groupes n'ont pas investi ce
n'est pas parce que je parle des grands
groupes sont régulièrement ce n'est pas
parce que le coût du travail était trop
important c'est parce que les charges
financières qui pèsent sur ces groupes
là les prélèvements des marchés
financiers parce que les dividendes
versés aux actionnaires sont trop
importants et c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
prendre de l'argent et pas sur le
travail qui est au contraire une des
conditions du redressement productif
national alors l'allègement des charges
c'est effectivement une des mesures de
retenu par le gouvernement a annoncé par
jean marc ayrault aujourd'hui 20
milliards d'allègements de charges
est ce que vous pensez pas quand même
que les entreprises d'aujourd'hui ont
besoin d'oxygène notamment pour investir
mais écoutez les ailes
il y a de l'argent le problème c'est de
savoir où il prend les ce qu'on appelle
les charges ne sont pas des charges
c'est un monde moi je conteste ce sont
des cotisations sociales
or la protection ski qui servent à
financer la protection sociale et la
protection sociale est un facteur qui
améliorent la productivité du travail
il vaut mieux avoir des salariés mieux
formés protégés devant l'un devant la
maladie protégés de voler les aléas de
la vie donc la protection sociale des
parents d ici à force de procéder par un
allègement successifs des cotisations
sociales et à force de présenter cela
comme des charges ou mais on cause de
cela je jeu et nous nous contestons ça
au contraire d'ailleurs il faudrait même
investir dans la sécurisation de
l'emploi c'est à dire donner une
nouvelle garantie aux salariés
c'est en tout cas une des pistes qui est
dans la négociation sociale en ce moment
donc il y aurait un progrès progrès de
civilisation à faire en matière de
sécurisation de l'emploi
donc c'est pas là par contre dans l'est
je le répète dans les charges
financières et les dividendes là il ya
de l'argent à trouver il faut je donne
un chiffre un sol puisqu'on parle
beaucoup de chiffres
la totalité des cotisations sociales
payées par les entreprises non
financières françaises ces 145 milliards
d'euros mais la totalité des dividendes
versés aux actionnaires et des charges
financières payée par ces mêmes
d'entreprises ces trois sondes 309
milliards d'euros deux fois plus donc il
y à deux fois plus d'argent qui va à la
rémunération de la finance que d'argent
qui va aux cotisations sociales donc
nous on dit protégeons au contraire ces
cotisations sociales parce qu'elles
aident à développer un emploi qualifié
et sur dont on a besoin pour faire une
production des productions utile un
parent formant tu es au contraire
diminuons la rente versée aux marchés
financiers aux actionnaires qui est une
honte qui ne sert à rien pour le
développement de l'est connaissent que
vous avez aimé en compensation de ces
allègements de charges que le
gouvernement les conditionnent par
exemple à des investissements
obligatoire pour les entreprises
il faudrait commencer il faudrait
commencer en vérité avant de parler de
nouveau choc de compétitivité
il faudrait mettre à plat d'ailleurs ça
pourrait être le parlement qu'ils
fassent ça qu'on crée une commission
denquête qu'on met à plat toutes les
exonérations de cotisations sociales qui
existent tous les qui sont déjà très
très nombreuses plusieurs dizaines de
milliards d'euros et qu'on évalue leur
efficacité
parce que c'est pas une recette nouvelle
nous on nous dit c'est là il ya un choc
nouveau etc
mais ça fait des années qu'on procède
par exonérations de cotisations sociales
est le résultat de ça c'est qu'on a
développé le chômage et détruit sept
cent mille emplois industriels depuis
dix ans donc nous allons continuer à
nous enfoncer dans cette pionnière
moscovici a dit aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale que ces mesures de
compétitivité allait permettre de créer
des centaines de milliers d'emplois mais
il faudra qu'ils nous expliquent comment
puisqu'on ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on va
donner de nouveaux vols de nouvelles
marges aux entreprises singulièrement
grandes entreprises est effectivement
sans contrôler l'utilisation ses marges
or pour le moment le problème c'est que
les marges existence qui sont déjà très
importante je rappelle quand même que
les groupes du cac 40 qui ont pleuré
misère dans le journal du dimanche
il ya quelques jours encore
fond et encore l'année dernière n'était
pas une des meilleures années 60 plus de
78 milliards de profits et bien ses
marges là à quoi elles sont utilisées
justement à rémunérer du capital qui ne
s'investit pas donc c'est ça qui doit
changer c'est la manière dont on utilise
ses marges mais elles existent pour
payer ces allègements de charges verra
notamment une hausse minime de la tva
notamment pour le taux principal de 19,6
jusqu'à 20 % françois hollande avait dit
qu'il ne toucherait pas à la tva est ce
que ça c'est un reniement des
engagements de campagne
c'est effectivement quelque chose qui
est contraire à ses engagements de
campagne
alors ils essayent le gouvernement 10
ans est monté à les moduler parce qu'on
bouge tel taux mais le résultat quand
même au total c'est qu'on va avoir dix
milliards d'impôts et singulièrement
d'impôts indirects de plus payées par
les salariés et la tva en plus est
l'impôt le plus injuste de tous on le
sait c'est celui qui touche
proportionnellement le plus les foyers
boulonnaise non je je je je pense que
l'heure n'est pas à alourdir la charge
pour les pour les salariés je répète il
faut se tourner vers les charges indues
qui sont servis à la finance et aux
marchés financiers d'ailleurs françois
hollande c'était pas moi qui l'ait au
bourget et ça a été un des tournants de
sa campagne a dit il faudra mener la
guerre à la finance où sont passés ces
belles paroles parce que en vérité
depuis 2008 et même sarkozy quand il ya
eu le déclenchement de la crise en 2008
ali nous avons laissé dériver la finance
donc on nous parle sans arrêt de réguler
la finance on nous parle de faire la
guerre à la finance mais à chaque fois
qu'il faut le faire il ya plus personne
auront vérité la vraie solution aller de
ce côté là d'un journal du dimanche à ce
week-end vous appeliez le gouvernement
un nouvel élan vers la gauche le compte
n'y est pas s'asseoir pas du tout pas du
tout mais nous allons continuer à
argumenter nous allons continuer à
convaincre nous allons continuer à faire
des propositions alternatives parce que
nous quand on tombe pas de critiquer le
rapport aux gallois
nous mettons sur la table des
propositions comme celle que je disais à
l'instant sur la taxation des dividendes
il faudrait aussi réorientés totalement
le crédit bancaire et financier il
faudrait qu'on puisse que les
entreprises qui investissent réellement
quitterait réellement de l'emploi ait
accès à un crédit à mathod mais pour ça
il faudrait reprendre le contrôle sur le
système bancaire et financier
il faudrait faire jouer un autre rôle à
la banque centrale européenne donc des
solutions existent donc pour le moment
nous n'avons pas conclu gouvernement à
l'évidence eh bien nous allons continuer
nous allons rencontrer d'ailleurs jean
marc ayrault
les parlementaires nous allons
rencontrer jonak et je dis eh bien nous
nous mettrons à nouveau sur la table des
propositions et je rappelle une chose
que nous allons rappeler au premier
ministre c'est que l'an dernier
las la majorité de gauche au sénat quand
et les campus est là est passé à gauche
a voté un collectif budgétaire qui
comportait une réorientation de 30
milliards d'euros par des mesures
diverses
eh bien ces mesures là nous nous
demandons leur application aujourd'hui
donc nous ne sommes pas certains deals
soit avec la droite on n'est pas du tout
avec la droite
nous nous allons défendre des mesures
qui ont été votées par la majorité de
gauche au sénat et qui aujourd'hui ne
sont pas mises en oeuvre et qui
éviterait d'aller chercher de l'argent
dans la poche des salariés qu'à laurent
sa journée la date anniversaire des six
premiers mois de françois hollande à
l'elysée
vous êtes un vrai déçu ce soir je pense
que le cap qui est pris actuellement
n'est pas le mot et qui ne permettra pas
de combattre la crise donc déçu en ce
qui me concerne je sais beaucoup de gens
sont déçus parce qu'ils ont voulu
changement moi je ne regrette pas
d'avoir chassé et que la sarkozie du
pouvoir parce que je pense que la
politique de droite et j'entends les
déclarations de la droite serait une
très grosse agressivité aujourd'hui mais
dès le début nous savions qu'ils
allaient avoir un problème dans la
politique gouvernementale et que la
contradiction le gouvernement allait
buter sur l'ampleur de la crise et sur
la faiblesse des moyens qu'ils mettaient
en face pourrait nous y sommes bien au
chaud répandant animer la fin de la
crise oui je crois
je crois que le gouvernement et françois
hollande ont considéré qu'il pouvait en
prenant des mesures qui visent à apaiser
les marchés en signant malgré tout
le traité budgétaire européen bien qu'il
n'ait pas obtenu sa renégociation est
d'ailleurs moscovici s'en vante
nous avons des bateaux parce que nous
sommes nous sommes complaisant avec avec
les marchés financiers mais en vérité
les chiffres du chômage continue
d'augmenter
la conjoncture est mauvaise il n'y a pas
de croissance donc si on continue dans
cette voie là nous n'aurons pas de
solution la crise et nous demandons un
changement de cap vers la gauche
effectivement il faut revenir à une
vraie politique de gauche on est pas
quand même on en est pas à souhaiter un
échec à ce gouvernement socialiste a dû
tout j'ai écouté si si j'ai créé avec
d'autres avec jean luc mélenchon le
front blanchi j'ai initié cette démarche
là c'est justement pour échapper à un
dilemme que nous avons déjà connu où on
est on se dit soit la droite va revenir
et ça sera plus catastrophique encore
soit nous avons l'échec de la gauche
selon moi j'achète ou mon action vise
échapper à ce dilemme là donc je lance
des appels et je continuerai de le faire
au gouvernement aux forces de gauche
dans le pays aux forces sociales et
citoyennes pour se mobiliser pour
obtenir un changement de cap pour que la
gauche justement réussissent une
politique de changement car laurent dans
cette émission d'un partenariat avec
orange et leur application tvcheck qu'on
a une question de michel est ce que vous
considérez comme un meilleur opposant au
gouvernement que l'ump non mais moi je
ne joue pas du tout dans la même
catégorie
l'ump est une opposition farouche au
gouvernement ils veulent récupérer le
pouvoir pour mener des politiques qui
seront plus brutale encore et moi je
n'ai rien à voir avec ça tout mon combat
est à l'opposé de la droite et de
l'extrême droite
je suis quelqu'un qui a des exigences et
qu'il ya un regard critique sur la
politique du gouvernement mais qui fait
des propositions alternatives de gauche
et qui défend je crois ce qui est l
aspiration d'une majorité de ceux qui
ont voulu changement au printemps
dernier
je pense que si la question vous est
posée via tivi tchèque et bien c'est
parce que plusieurs textes ont été
rejeté au sénat notamment du fait d'une
alliance un peu improbable entre 20
groupes est ici et l'ump
alors on peut se demander plus
généralement si le front de gauche est
entré dans une phase active d'opposition
à la politique du gouvernement
mathilde bélanger
enquêter pour nous je vous propose de
regarder ce reportage et après vous
réagirez les parlementaires communistes
oseront ils allaient jusqu'à la
déclaration de guerre depuis quelques
semaines le ton monte entre les
socialistes et leurs alliés d'extrême
gauche le pcf prévient qu'il ne votera
pas le budget 2013 ni la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale si
ces amendements ne sont pas adoptées une
menace prise au sérieux par la majorité
je les appelle un peu de responsabilité
quand on est dans une majorité même si
on n'est pas au gouvernement
on doit accepter le pacte majoritaire et
sur les sujets aussi importants que dans
la loi de finances pour connaître
d'autres textes que le gouvernement
porte un peu de responsabilité
la semaine dernière déjà deux textes ont
été rejeté au sénat suite à une alliance
inédite des voix du front de gauche et
de la droite
car si les socialistes ont la majorité
absolue à l'assemblée ce n'est pas le
cas au sénat un avantage dont les
communistes entendent bien se servir
pour peser sur les décisions
il ya un problème de travail en commun
les sénatrices et sénateurs communistes
ne sont jamais
entendu par des membres du gouvernement
sur tel ou tel projet de loi je
considère qu'en étendant la majorité ici
au sénat nous pourrions avoir une
approche commune sur un certain nombre
de textes pour voir jusqu'où
effectivement nos amendements pourraient
être adoptées et un assassinat sur le
pcf n'est pas dans l'opposition mais le
parti multiplie les critiques à l'égard
du gouvernement et la discorde semble
profonde
les annonces de jean marc ayrault sur la
compétitivité ont provoqué nouvelle
levée de boucliers à gauche c'est toute
la politique d'austérité qui est mise en
cause
il y a six mois presque jour pour jour
françois hollande était élu grâce à une
majorité dont nous sommes une majorité
populaire pour le changement nous votons
ce qui va dans la bonne direction
on a voté le projet de loi renforçant la
sru on s'est satisfait de la suppression
du bouclier fiscal mais nous ne voterons
pas ce qui renforce l'austérité ce qui
renvoie notre pays dans le mur et
surtout ce qui est pas à l'aune du
changement attendu dans notre pays
à la demande de pierre laurent les
parlementaires communistes seront reçus
jeudi à matignon
l'objectif trouver à tout prix un
terrain d'entente sur le budget 2013
pour éviter l'image désastreuse d'une
majorité divisée
alors le fond c'est elle ou non dans
l'opposition dans la majorité réponse
avec katell prigent de la fp qui avec
nous sur le plateau pierre laurent pour
vous interroger ce sera un bon soir
qu'apple entendu vous avez fait rejeter
deux textes avec l'aide de l'ump donc
justement faites vous encore dans la
majorité présidentielle
êtes vous dans l'opposition écoutez
d'abord nous n'avons pas fait rouge
c'est des textes avec l'ump nous n'avons
pas réussi à nous mettre d'accord avec
le gouvernement sur ces textes et nous
avons proposé au gouvernement des portes
de sortie à cela je prends les deux
exemples sur la loi sur l'énergie à la
loi mme roth nous allons proposer au
gouvernement de voter tous les articles
avec les quelques étions d'accord de les
sortir loin et de sortir l'arctique qui
faisait problème que nous considérons
dont heureux parce que mettant le doigt
dans une dérégulation des tarifs et de
l'euro discuté dans une autre discussion
donc
étions prêts à voter l'essentiel de la
loi c était quand même à la base même du
texte
c'était difficile pour le gouvernement
de revenir puisque cet article puisqu'il
s'agit en l'occurrence d'obtenir en
d'accord majoritaire puisque cet article
fait problème dans la majorité on peut
prendre du temps pour débattre de cette
question là on nous a dit non non non
même soit vous votez tout soit vous
votez rien donc nous avons été mis dans
la situation de ne pas voter parce que
nous n'acceptons pas cette mise au pied
du mur et donc le choix d'avoir été umut
cette logique là revient au gouvernement
et non pas au groupe communiste au sénat
mais nous assumons effectivement le fait
qu' on nous mettra pas au pied du mur de
cette manière là et le sénateur
socialiste françois patriat de reportage
parle de pacte majoritaire mais le pacte
qui a été passé avec les français c'est
faire reculer le chômage
c'est mener la guerre à la finance c'est
renégocier le traité européen
voilà c'est ce pacte lan qui a été le
pacte du changement qui a été passé avec
les français que nous défendons et quand
il n'est pas respectée et bien il suffit
pas de nous dire il de faire appel à la
discipline il faut nous convaincre que
effectivement ces mesures vont dans le
bon sens et nous ne le pensons pas est
ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression vous
auriez plus d'appuis d'apport en
participant justement au gouvernement et
en ayant un peu comme les verts les
verts finalement arrive à faire reculer
ce par exemple sur le gaz de schiste
écoutez le la participation au
gouvernement le problème devant lequel
nous sommes aujourd'hui ils furent
depuis on fait le d2 puis la nomination
du premier ministre marc ayrault quand
jean marc ayrault a été nommé premier
ministre et après les législatives comme
la question du gouvernement s'est posée
j'ai eu jean marc ayrault au téléphone
et je lui opposer une question très
simple puisqu'il savait qu'on n'étions
pas d'accord avec l'ensemble des 60
mesures et surtout présidentielle et
surtout une considérions que ses seules
mesures ne suffira pas à faire face à la
crise puisque nous avons avancé dans la
campagne d'autres propositions et que
nos voix avaient été nécessaires pour la
victoire
je lui ai dit est ce qu'on va s'en tenir
à cela il m'a dit oui
auger je n'ai qu'une seule feuille de
route ce sont les 60 engagements de
françois hollande
donc dès le départ le signal qui nous a
été donné c'est il n'y a pas de
négociation possible sur le cadre de la
politique gouvernementale donc nous
avons jugé qu'on saurions plus efficace
à ne pas participer au gouvernement et à
mener avec la liberté de voix et de vote
qui est la nôtre
un travail constructif ce travail nous
le continent et nous allons le continuer
jusqu'au moment où seront entendus du
coup pierre laurent
quelles vont être les axes de
discussions jeudi après-midi quand vous
allez aller à matignon rencontrer le
premier ministre est bien par exemple
c'est bien par exemple je le disais
précédemment nous allons revenir dans
les propositions problème c'est le
projet de loi de finances et le projet
loi de financement a déjà bien régalé
avec des propositions précises que nous
allons déjà déposé comme amendement à
l'assemblée nationale et qui n'ont pas
été retenues mais nous allons y revenir
en argumentant encore sur sa par exemple
nous proposons que l'impôt sur le revenu
soit plus progressif il faut une tranche
supérieure à la tranche des 40 5%
il y avait par exemple une tranche à 50%
pour les revenus supérieurs à 380 mille
euros dans le paquet des 30 milliards
d'euros de collecte correctif budgétaire
votée l'an dernier par la majorité de
gauche du sénat donc ces mesures elles
sont possibles demandé jeudi à jean marc
ayrault
un peu plus de respect comme vous
l'avait déjà fait il ya une lettre à non
mais là il faut passer au concret et pas
seulement du respect dans la mesure où
le premier ministre accepte de nous
recevoir
direction un peu plus un meilleur
rendement de l'impôt d'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune parce que le
gouvernement ne vient de rétablir qu'une
partie de liens simple donc nous avons
aujourd'hui un isf allégé très allégé
par rapport à ce qui existait
précédemment
donc on a fait une partie du chemin par
rapport à ce qu a défait la droite
nous allons demander à un dégel c'est un
peu technique mais des trucs de la
revalorisation des tranches du barème de
l'impôt sur le revenu en gros ça veut
dire que comme on n'a pas revaloriser
ces tranches
il ya des gens qui mécaniquement vont
monter deux tranches ou rentrer dans
l'imposition revenus alors qu'il ne
l'était pas avant donc ça concerne
beaucoup de gens donc quand on nous dit
qu'on n'a pas augmenté les impôts pour
les couches moyennes c'est pas vrai il
ya
ou de gens qui ont des revenus modestes
qui vont être touchés par une
augmentation des impôts sur le revenu et
fiat avaient un rendement aussi ça les
pigeons l'amendement sur les pigeons sur
lequel nous demandons de revenir surtout
qu'en plus on continue d'en rajouter
maintenant avec le show est entendue et
bien si nous ne sommes pas entendus nous
discuterons dans le groupe au sénat et
il est probable si nous ne sommes pas
entendus comme ça a été le cas à
l'assemblée nationale le comme les
députés de l'assemblée nationale de
notre groupe
il ya eu nous abstiendrons sur la partie
recettes du budget mais ce n'est pas ce
que nous souhaitons si nous allons à
matignon jeudi après midi
c'est pour répondre c'est pour être
entendu vu que la majorité très très
court s'ils voient seulement en avance
pour la gauche
et bien c'est pour ça qu'il faut
discuter puisque et que y
si vous voulez la place que nous que
nous revendiquons dans ce débat là ce
n'est pas une place un dû sans les voix
du front de gauche à l'élection
présidentielle il n'y avait pas de
victoire possible
donc la réalité de la majorité et celle
là on doit pouvoir discuter sur la table
je répète que nous mettons sur la table
des propositions qui ont été votées par
la majorité de gauche au sénat parce que
justement de ces vois pas du tout pas du
tout pas du tout écouter quand je quand
je lis le rapport gallois
quand j'entends les dirigeants de droite
l'applaudir dès demain quand je lis le
programme de respectivement de françois
fillon et jean françois copé qui propose
d'en rajouter dans tous les domaines qui
propose de mettre à bas toute
législation sur le droit d'être sur le
temps au travail
quand je lis le programme de la droite
quand je vois les rapprochements avec
l'extrême droite quand j'entends les
dérives dans la bouche de jean françois
copé je veux dire heureusement que ces
gens ne gouverne plus le pays met donc
je n'ai aucun regret sur le choix
politique que nous avons font de matelas
droite au printemps dernier maintenant
il y à un débat dans la gauche et nous
allons le mener jusqu'au bout parce que
nous rendons service au pays parce que
la politique mise en oeuvre par le
gouvernement ne va pas atteindre ses
objectifs c'est bien ce qui nous
inquiète reste qu'en soit le maintien
est ce que vous sentez vraiment que le
gouvernement a entendu votre message et
qu'il est véritablement prêt à négocier
avec vos fins j'ai des doutes
écouter parce que je lis les
déclarations des uns et des autres en
même temps j'ai l'impression qu'il y ait
un débat dans l'hérault dans les rangs
socialistes
jojo côtoie aussi sur le terrain quand
je vais dans les entreprises dans les
quartiers je connais beaucoup de gens
qui ont voté pour le changement au
printemps dernier qui n'ont pas
forcément voté pour le front gauche mais
pour d'autres formations
je pense qu'il ya une somme non nous
sommes nous sommes pour notre part on
phase avec une attente qui est forte
dans le pays que le cap de la politique
gouvernementale prennent un autre tour
que le cap actuel ce que justement dans
cette attente vous pourriez anticiper
une participation au gouvernement ou
être un recours comme dit jean luc
mélenchon écouter tout ce qui est à
l'ordre du jour pour le moment c'est
d'essayer de faire avancer les choix
majoritaire
la participation au gouvernement
français en vue ce qui se passe pour le
moment
on en est pas là donc pour le moment je
pense que si nous voulons être utiles et
nous essayons d'être utile c'est en
continuant à maintenir notre voix à
féron temps des critiques constructives
et à faire des propositions alternatives
et à essayer de convaincre dans le pays
que ses propositions seraient plus
utiles à combattre la crise que celles
qui sont prises à l'heure actuelle donc
nous allons continuer ce travail là et
l'idée du recours bon moi c'est une
formule que je ne comprends pas bien
parce que aujourd'hui nous sommes il y à
une urgence
donc la question de réorienter la
politique gouvernementale c'est une
question qui ne se pose pas non 3 donc à
dans cinq ans c'est une question qui se
pose maintenant j'ai avec mes l'argent
lui dit qu'il se serait pas abstenu sur
le budget qu'il arrive voté contre et
c'est à dire qu'il ya des lignes à
l'intérieur des fantoches écouter les
groupes parlementaires discutent nous
avons nous faisons des choix que nous
essayons de faire le plus le plus
sérieux possible donc nous avons par
exemple la ratification du traité
budgétaire nous avons voté composa
votant contre en l'état en tous cas nous
avons voté contre à l'assemblée
et s'il n'ya pas de changement est ce
qu'on la même chose au sénat contre le
projet de loi sur la sécurité sociale le
projet de financement de la sécurité
sociale
parce que il n'ya vraiment pas le
minimum de réorientation nécessaire par
rapport à la situation catastrophique
notamment dans les hôpitaux
maintenant dans le budget est
singulièrement pis classement parle de
vote sur la partie recettes
il y à quelques améliorations sur la
partie rossite puisque le bouclier
fiscal a été a été mis en cause il y a
il y à une tranche supplémentaire même
si elle paraît très faible etc
nous ne disons pas il ne s'est rien
passé mais ça ne va pas et c'est pas du
tout à la hauteur donc l'abstention
à l'heure qu'il est nous paraître un
choix
qui exprime clairement ce que nous ce
que nous voulons dire pas dans
l'opposition pas non plus vraiment dans
la majorité
parce que le cas par cas oui on voit ce
qui va dans le bon sens
on critique ce qui nous paraît pas
suffisant et on agit pour continuer à
faire évoluer les choses
nous ne sommes pas dans une posture
politique c'est pour ça que le débat sur
vous êtes dans la majorité vous avez
l'opposition
finalement je sais bien qu'on fasse tout
le temps la question mais nous intéresse
assez peu dans la mesure où nous nous
avons contribué à une majorité politique
dans le pays et nous l'avons fait en
connaissance de cause et en connaissant
les contradictions auxquelles nous
allions avoir à faire avec le parti
socialiste
et nous l'avons fait pour les raisons
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure le sentiment
que la droite
il fallait vraiment pas la laisser au
pouvoir maintenant nous menons le
travail pour faire avancer les choses et
c'est comme ça que nous allons continuer
à faire
merci quatre scènes bien laurent vous
invité samedi prochain la presse a
enterré le parti communiste français a
retiré l'enterrement du parti communiste
s'est amusé avec ça pourquoi parce que
nous allons rassembler plusieurs
centaines de nouveaux adhérents au parti
communiste nous avons fait plus de 6000
un nouveau nouvelles adhésions dont les
derniers mois au cours de l'année même
plus maintenant et cette jeunesse qui a
commencé à envahir le parti communiste
eh bien nous la jugeons pas assez
visibles dont nous allons montrer ce
qu'il en est de la jeunesse du parti
communiste on a compris en tout cas que
ici au sénat pierre laurent vous aviez
bien rebooster votre groupe
parlementaire une opposition franche sur
certains textes vous dire que vous avez
été à bonne école pendant les dernières
campagnes avec jean luc mélenchon alors
pierre laurent est il sous influence
réponse tout de suite avec ce reportage
d'alexandra colis l'eau il est d'abord
resté dans l'ombre de jean luc mélenchon
écrasé le temps d'une campagne
présidentielle par le poids médiatique
d'un candidat du front de gauche fort en
gueule mais la promesse des grands soirs
électoraux s'est envolé mélenchon en
retrait pierre laurent reprend donc du
terrain le verbe plus haut les
propositions plus radicale il marche
dans les pas de son camarade jean-luc
c'est pas le c'est pas le professeur de
pierre laurent voilà mais on s'influence
tous
lorsqu'on fait tous le mieux voilà on
est on est ainsi fait responsables
politiques façon c'est vrai nom dans la
vie de tous les jours où chacun des
qualités clair que jean-luc qu'on fait
on fait difficilement mieux aujourd'hui
comme comme orateur donc voilà on a tous
regardé tiers on l'entend plus parce
qu'ils les sénateurs il est
parlementaire donc aujourd'hui nous
groupe à l'assemblée au sénat d'autant
plus au sénat où les socialistes ont pas
la majorité sol et bien fonction de nos
vitrines est plus importante
jean luc mélenchon locomotive du front
de gauche a donc sorti le pcf de l'oubli
laissant à pierre laurent la place pour
déployer son parti il fallait affirmer
il fallait s'affirmer au début le front
de gauche n'étaient pas dans le paysage
il était à 4% dans les sondages est où
maintenant il est dans le paysage à plus
de 11% et maintenant faut
faire deux séances pour cent une force
le pcf rappelle désormais que sans ces
130 milles encartés et son ancrage
historique sur le terrain le front de
gauche n'ira pas loin
pierre laurent jean-luc mélenchon dit
sur son blog s'être mis un petit peu en
retrait délibérément dit il est ce que
c'est parce que le message ne passe plus
ou parce que vous avez pris le pouvoir
écoutez je ça il faut lui poser la
question
oui mais moi j'ai pas de réponse à cette
question là la vie politique elle est
très intense
en tout cas en ce qui me concerne j'ai
pas j'ai pas envie et je pense pas que
ce soit utile de se mettre en retrait
bon vous savez on est on est au combat
quotidiennement parlement mais dans le
pays
donc j'essaye d'être utile le plus
possible en étant le plus présent
possible et pas ça vous change un petit
peu qu'ils se soient mis dans ce retrait
délibéré et et vous savez je sais que ça
occupe énormément mais c'est ça
fonctionne de manière très simple je dis
je dis quelque chose depuis le début
relisez ce que je dis depuis le front
gauche que le parti communiste a initié
volontairement justement pour rassembler
prendre estimant toutes les forces qui
sont des forces alternatives à gauche
qui ont une propose des propositions
plus audacieuse que celles qui sont
mises en oeuvre par le parti socialiste
mais je dis toujours la même chose
ce qui fait la force du front de gauche
c'est d'avoir été c'est d'être justement
le carrefour d'énergies diverses
donc il faut pas chercher à ski et au
front de gauche
insolent leader il y en aura plusieurs
et il y en aura toujours plusieurs
mariages avec jean luc mélenchon vous le
referiez s'il fallait refaire tout
depuis le début depuis 2008 mais écoutez
j'étais en 2008 ge était le rapporteur
au congrès du parti communiste sur cette
stratégie de front unitaire
donc j'ai porté cette stratégie là et
quand nous avons lancé cette offre aux
politiques et bien jean luc mélenchon
est sorti du parti socialiste à ce
moment là roux créant le parti gauche
pour travailler avec lundi qu'il a fait
travailler
oui mais ça c'est ce qu'on raconte je
sais bien que ça les gens je les ai déjà
dit ça aussi plusieurs fois les gens qui
pensent pouvoir faire une opé assure
parti communiste ils ont du boulot parce
que non seulement il n'y aura pas de
paix assure le parti communiste
mais le parti communiste est en plein
renouveau il ya énormément de gens qui
adhèrent et qui rejoint l'accélération
d'affaires voulu faire et dire non je ne
crois pas je pense qu il ya eu un débat
dans le front de gauche reste que le
front gauche devait devenir une seule
formation politique et au début le parti
de gauche de jean luc mélenchon était
pour cette option là mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes tous d'accord
la formule actuelle qui est une formule
de front unitaire qui ne fusionne pas
les organisations et qui les respecte et
qui permet justement à de nouvelles
forces de nous rejoindre en étant
respecté pour qu'elles sont et plus
efficace donc l'idée qui était celle du
parti communiste au départ est
maintenant devenue celle de toutes les
formations du front gauche sur ce point
l'altérité qui va peut-être rattrapé
jean luc mélenchon puisque le conseil
constitutionnel est saisi d'un recours
contre l'élection législative à hénin
beaumont
cette élection pourrait être annulée on
rappelle que jean luc mélenchon avait
été candidat contre marine le pen est ce
qu'il est les craintes à us qui doit à
nouveau il y aller jean luc mélenchon
écoutez bon d'abord pour le moment il
n'y a pas d'annulations ma connaissance
il ya un recours de marine le pen n'y a
pas d'annulations ont travaillé dans
l'art et dans la politique fiction et il
n'y a pas d'autre choix que d'y aller
finalement
et ensuite et ensuite il faudra examiner
la situation si jamais il y avait un
validation il faut regarder les raisons
de cette invalidation
la situation dans la circonscription ne
s'est pas améliorée depuis parce que la
situation sociale comme dans le reste du
pays est très difficile les affaires du
parti socialiste continue de se
développer dans la région là bas donc
être situation qui s'est dégradée et et
je lui tendrais traitement le risque
d'une élection marine le pen sérieux
donc moi je crois qu'à ce moment là il
faudra avec les militants sur place
examiner la situation et savoir quelle
est la meilleure stratégie pour empêcher
cette élection et pour permettre un
député de gauche d'être élu dans cette
circonscription
et quelle est la réponse à cette
question moi je ne la porte
mais pas ce soir parce que c'est
pourquoi il faut essayer de gagner un
peu de temps on n'imagine pas fier le
rang que le lundi quand vous vous
réunissez place du colonel fabien
cette question n'est pas été abordés eh
bien figurez-vous qu'elle a été elle a
été abordée pour la première fois lundi
matin
je n'y étais pas personnellement mais la
coordination du front gauche pour la
première fois à évoquer cette situation
lundi matin et pas avant cabella et est
là et elle a tout simplement dit ce que
je vous dis c'est à dire qu'il fallait
examiner la situation ont discuté avec
les avec les camarades sur place et
attendre de voir d'amour s'est avéré le
parti socialiste pour avoir une union de
la gauche dès le premier tour il faudra
discuter avec toulouse de cette
situation de en tout cas c'est mon
opinion il faudra prendre la mesure de
la situation et voir qui la stratégie la
plus adaptée un candidat de l'union de
la gauche de droite et sert non pas que
je n'ai pas d'à priori sur la solution
au dessus doit être à deux kilos seriez
pour repartir dans une campagne à hénin
beaumont on rappelle que cette campagne
avait été quand même un peu un torrent
d'insultés avec les histoires des faux
tracts
vous étiez pas tellement pour la
candidature de jean-luc mélenchon à
hénin beaumont au départ pour la
regrettée non pas du tout dont il nous
avions une discussion à l'époque était
une discussion très collective et la
décision que nous avions prise était une
discussion à laquelle nous avions tous
tous adhéré donc quand jean-luc à
l'époque est allé dans la
circonscription en accord avec les
militants de la circonscription
ça a été une décision collective à
laquelle j'ai participé que j'assume et
la politique du front contre front ça
vous a desservi un petit peu ou pas non
mais écoutez ça c'est l'image qu'on a
cherché randonnée nous avons sonné dans
la campagne présidentielle
un combat et heureusement que nous avons
menées nous avons pris la tête du combat
contre le front national
et je crois que nous avons eu raison de
le faire autre chose est de dire que
notre seul ennemi était le front
national et cette caricature la qui a
réduit notre campagne as à un moment
donné que nous n'avons pas porter nous
mêmes et qui a été portée effectivement
à
réunis a réduit ce qu'était le message
que nous envoyer puisque nous étions
dans une campagne plus bien plus large
que ça et même aujourd'hui on voit bien
que le danger qui existent face si
jamais il y avait échec de la gauche que
je ne souhaite pas c'est un danger de
droite de droite et d'extrême droite
mais les deux ensemble j'ai remarqué
d'ailleurs personne n'en fait trop de
publicité que marine le pen a dit
qu'elle serait d'accord pour aller
manifester avec jean françois copé
oui mais c'est que ça vous gérez non ça
ne m'a ça ne m'étonne pas ça ne m'étonne
pas ça veut bien dire que le danger
auquel nous avons à faire face
c'est bien un danger de droite avec son
extrême droite mais l'extrême droite
n'est en aucun cas une alternative à la
politique de la droite
notre autre question toujours sur votre
parti situez vous savez qu'on est en
partenariat avec orange et l'application
tvcheck cc calme y est qui vous pose
cette question quelle sera l'attitude de
votre parti vis-à-vis du ps dans le
cadre des municipales et des cantonales
préfet ce qu'il y aura accord
écoutez moi je crois que les élections
municipales sont des élections
extrêmement importante parce que les
politiques de services publics locaux
les politiques de démocratie locale
c'est à ce niveau là qu'on pollen et
d'ailleurs il ya eu des attaques
récurrentes de la droite pendant qu'il
était au pouvoir contre la démocratie
locale
il ya une tentative de réforme
territoriale que nous avons en partie
écartés depuis l'arrivée de la gauche
qui était extrêmement dangereuses et ce
danger persiste donc moi je crois que
aller à la bataille des municipales avec
l'ambition d'avoir partout le maximum
d'élus du front de gauche soit dans des
configurations front de gauche dans soit
dans des configurations unitaire sera
indispensable mais maintenant il faudra
regarder la situation il ya les débats
nationaux il ya les débats locaux nous
allons là aussi apprécier l'ensemble de
cette situation mais moi je crois que
notre stratégie doit être une stratégie
de rassemblement large pour conquérir le
maximum d'opposition
multi pierre laurent avec qui
concrètement le parti socialiste mais on
savait les élections municipales
comment ça se passe des élections
municipales dans une ville c'est pas
seulement les listes ne sont pas
seulement faite par les parties il ya
des citoyens sur les listes
il ya des gens du mouvement associatif
il ya des légendes ya beaucoup
d'attaquants d'un accord nationaux il y
a aussi des internationaux et donc il
faudra examiner ça effectivement
les villes qui sont actuellement à
gauche sont très le sont dans la plupart
des cas par tradition par des coalitions
de gauche et moi je pense que avant de
tirer un trait sur ça il faut mieux se
demander si on va servir les populations
si on va avoir les moyens de mener des
politiques de services publics locaux de
démocratie locale de lutte contre
l'austérité qui frappe aussi les
collectivités locales
donc on va aller avec des objectifs
concrets mais ce qui est certain c'est
qu'on fera des offres de rassemblement
des questions de société le mariage
homosexuel est ce que vous avez été
choqué par ce qu'a dit et l'intrusion de
la religion dans ce débat sur le mariage
pour tous et notamment de l'église
catholique
écoutez vous savez que nous sommes
totalement favorables au mariage pour
tous où nous avions déposé des projets
de loi déjà depuis longtemps sur cette
question ou sommes favorables à
l'adoption et même à l'accès à la
procréation médicalement assistée
donc nous sommes maintenant que que ce
texte provoque un débat de société
nous le savons donc c'est un débat qui
traverse la société française qui
traverse l archerie ou différente les
différentes formations politiques mais
aussi les contres donc que l'église
donne son opinion ce débat elle a le
droit de le faire
c'est un débat de société dans lequel à
mes yeux elle a le droit d'un tel peut
intervenir à loin d'intervenir
maintenant
convaincre et d'ailleurs moi j'ai eu
récemment dans des dents des des
conversations dans sur le terrain avec
des militants de gauche qui sont des
militants catholiques qui se pose ce
type de questions et j'ai envie qu'on
essaie discussion a donc je n'ai pas
envie de stigmatiser non plus les
oppositions qui ont fait ceci étant dit
dans les propos d'andré 23
j'ai entendu des choses invraisemblables
et totalement excessives je ne suis
prendre 30 mai mais je veux un dialogue
qui soit un dialogue pour faire avancer
les choses avec tous ceux qui parfois
ont des réticences sur autre débat qui
créait beaucoup de remous l'algérie les
questions sur l'algérie lago vous voulez
faire du 19 mars une journée nationale
du souvenir en mémoire des victimes de
l'algérie l'ump dénonce une séance de
repentance est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec eux non seulement je ne suis pas
d'accord avec cela mais je pense que la
reconnaissance par la france de de son
passé colonial et le fait que nous d'une
part est une nécessité vous savez que
nous avons fait adopter au sénat un
texte pour la reconnaissance du crime 17
7 au 17 octobre 61 et je pense que c'est
une très bonne chose et que et qu'il
faudrait aller plus loin d'ailleurs
parce qu'il ya eu d'autres crimes
coloniaux qui mériterait d'être reconnu
par l'état par l'état français sur le 19
mars il s'agit d'autre chose
le 19 marques marques en fait la faune
de la guerre d'algérie même si donc
c'est une c'est une date de paix et je
crois que ce serait important de
effectivement de marie ça n'a rien à
voir
la droite nous parle de repentance mais
c'est pas ça il s'agit de reconnaître la
vérité de regarder notre passé on fasse
et de construire des relations saines et
durables avec le peuple jeudi matin
petite dernière question pierre laurent
sur la sphère aurore martin manuel valls
nie toute implication dans l'arrestation
de cette militante basque est extradé en
espagne au nom de la séparation des
pouvoirs dit-il est ce qui attend qu un
fonctionnement normal des institutions
françaises
non je pense que cette affaire est très
grave nous sommes nous scandaliser de ce
qui s'est passé je crois que c'est la
première fois que la france arrête une
ressortissante française et l'extra dans
de telles conditions avec une telle
vitesse je crois que s'il n'y a pas de
précédent
donc je pense que c'est une affaire
extrêmement grave nous nous avons la
police française a arrêté en rond martin
l'a remis à la justice qui l'a remis aux
autorités espagnoles
au nom du 2
du mandat européen donc c'est une
première ça n'a jamais existé et essai
et c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
inquiétant et je sais que ça soulève de
l'indignation pas seulement dans nos
rangs pas seulement dans les milieux qui
qui sont proches d'henri martin mais y
compris chez les parlementaires
socialistes de la région et dans des
sphères très large de la société qui
sont extrêmement inquiets de ce qui
s'est produit et il faudrait que la
clarté soit faite parce que les membres
du gouvernement ne peuvent pas se
renvoyer la balle on disant qu'aucun n'a
rien fait et que personne ne sait ce qui
s'est passé on fera croire à personne
on a arrêté en martin et que personne ne
sait qu'on l'a remettait aux autorités
espagnoles
l'information est forcément remonter à
paris quelque part donc il faudra faire
la clarté sur ce qui s'est passé
merci beaucoup pierre laurent d'avoir
été un autre invité ce soir merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis et très bonne
soirée sur l'antenne de public sénat
le vrai courage gilles leclair s'est pas
d'augmenter les impôts tout le monde
sait le faire nicolas sarkozy est parti
mais la crise est à partir la politique
économique du gouvernement
je lui donnerai un zéro pointé tous les
matins à 8 heures 15
guillaume durand et gilles leclair
reçoivent une personnalité politique
dans l'invité politique reconstruire sa
crédibilité
reconstruire sa popularité il faut pas
préjuger on peut juger après en
partenariat avec radio classique
l'invité politique
tous les matins à 8h 15 en direct sur
public sénat
bonjour à tous bienvenue à banne ce
merveilleux village reculé sur tous
perchés quelque part dans le sud de
l'ardèche ici une bataille a marqué le
pays à la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale une embuscade hardiment menées
par les partisans les résistants c'était
à quelques kilomètres d'ici
dans la vallée une bataille d'envergure
qui a stoppé net la progression d'une
importante colonne allemande en route
vers le nord du pays
un homme occupe une place très
singulière dans cet épisode de
l'histoire cet homme c'est paul maës il
était maire du village
en ce mois de juillet 1944 et depuis
très peu de temps depuis moins d'un an
la toute nouvelle école de ban porte
désormais son nom
oh
voilà je me trouve maintenant dans cette
magnifique salle de classe de la toute
nouvelle école de banel un an et demi à
peine j'ai rejoins l'un des professeurs
de l'école frédéric le clech bonjour
bonjour avec devant vous et bien vos
élèves aux enfants une classe de cm2 cm1
bonjour à tous alors frédéric le clech
cette école s'appelle paul maes est ce
que c'est un nom que vous connaissiez il
y encore quelques mois je les ai
découverts quand ils ont nommé cette
école et auparavant n'étant pas moi-même
debanne auparavant je ne connaissais pas
du tout ce personnage vous avez
peut-être regarder les plaques qui sont
sur l'école elle même est ce que vous
êtes intéressé à ce personnage demain à
partir de ce moment là j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à me demander d'abord
qu'est-ce qu'il avait bien pu faire et
puis d'où venait ce nom si qui n'est pas
un patronyme d'origine ardéchoise
française et donc j'ai fait quelques
recherches
alors votre école les enfants elle
s'appelle paul mann est ce que ce nom
vous le connaissez est ce que ça vous
dit quelque chose
bah j'ai pas connue mais c'était le
maire de vannes 2-2 ce que je suis ce
que j'ai écouté ce que j'ai entendu tant
ici alors paul maïs il était maire de
bad mais quand elle vers lui quand il ya
eu la bataille de ban et c'était quand
ça
en 1804 quarante quatre pôles maïs était
maire en 1944 c'est à dire pendant la
guerre pendant la guerre oui la seconde
guerre mondiale il a sauvé le village il
était maire il a il l'a chauvel a été
réaliste en est là il a combattu
légalement et c'est bien ce qu'il a fait
peu de masse je trouve ça non eric avec
le clech merci beaucoup de nous avoir
accueillis chez vous dans votre salle de
classe sinon qui vous remercie
à très bientôt on va essayer maintenant
d'en savoir un peu plus sur paul maes et
sur cette fameuse bataille de bam
merci les enfants à très bientôt au
revoir
alors vous l'avez compris en cette fin
du mois de juillet 1944 paul maes le
maire de bam n'est pas tout à fait un
personnage comme les autres son action
elle intervient quelques jours à peine
après ce qu'on appelle ici la bataille
de ban autrement dit la plus grande
bataille de la résistance ici dans le
département de la neige
je rejoint raul galatto il est historien
c'est l'un des meilleurs spécialistes de
cette résistance ardéchoise
bonjour raul galatto est-ce que one
aujourd'hui ensemble au village tel
qu'il existait en juillet 1944 pour
l'échangé louit avec son aspect
pittoresque le juger sur sa colline le
rochers calcaires les chais ruines du
vieux château bon il ya des quelques
maisons nouvelles mais pour l'essentiel
oui c'est très typique
ban a joué un rôle tout à fait
particulier dans cette résistance
ardéchoise eh oui ban se trouve situé en
bordure d'une route à l'époque où une
route nationale qui avait une importance
stratégique pour les armées allemandes
d'occupation dans tout le sud de la
france y compris le languedoc et les
volontaires d
forces françaises de l'intérieur
c'est-à-dire les portes armée de la
résistante ont été amenés à livrer
quelques escarmouches contre chez congo
allemand qui circulait qui étaient ces
résistants qui ont participé à la
bataille de bain des jeunes volontaires
paysans et autres de la région de bâle
ont rejoints par des maquisards et épais
venus du gard principalement des
ouvriers mineurs dans des cévennes il ya
eu évidemment parmi les réfugiés qui ont
rejoint la résistance plusieurs l'ancien
républicains espagnols qu'on a retrouvés
dans cette compagnie aussi donc c'était
très diversifié bon au départ il y avait
quelques centaines de volontaires le 6
juin
fin juillet devait y avoir cinq ou six
mille volontaires dans le département de
l'ardèche qui était organisé en compagne
et donc encadré convenablement on avait
trouvé quand même quelques militaires
des anciens qui avait fait la guerre de
14-18 tous acquis près qu'ils avaient
quelques compétences c'est ce qui leur a
permis de livrer un combat qui
finalement était le premier combat
victorieux à en ardèche qui a précédé de
quelques jours la libération de privas
la première préfecture de france libérée
par la résistance le 12 août
avant même le débarquement des troupes
alliées jeu les côtes méditerranéennes
ce qui a été tout à l'honneur de la
résistance ardéchoise merci beaucoup
raul galatto vous le disiez à l'instant
même
cette bataille de ban intervient dans un
contexte particulier les alliés ont
débarqué en normandie
deux mois avant le 6 juin 1944
le débarquement de provence n'a pas
encore eu lieu y aura lieu le 15 août de
cette même année
autrement dit l'armée allemande ici sur
cette terre ardéchoise est sur le qui
vive
marie lebon en normandie le débarquement
allié ouvre un nouveau front
l'allemagne a besoin de renforts des
divisions blindées ans